this is a production of Cornell
University
I'll be focusing on presenting what some
of the stuff that I've been doing within
the soils lab over the past few months
and that is malting barley water
sensitivity so a little bit of an
outline will give some context what is
water sensitivity why is it important
and how is it measured because that kind
of helps a person conceptualize what it
actually is some historical literature
about it
populations that have been using to
answer some of the questions that we've
asked and the results in conclusions
thus far along with future steps so some
context what is water sensitivity so
it's one of the traits that contributes
to moulting quality it's basically
reaction to steeping conditions that
causes a differential germination of
malting barley under different water
concentrations so essentially it's an
induced dormancy or a secondary dormancy
so after the dormancy has been broken in
the original after the original dormancy
has been broken exposure to certain
steeping conditions can cause the barley
to have a secondary dormancy which in
turn will lead to no germination and
this is important because malting barley
has to be molded or germinated in order
to be turned into beer and as you can
imagine if you have a secondary dormancy
you won't have any germination which
stops the entire process in its tracks
and makes people sad because you cannot
make a beer so just a little bit more
insight on what it is how its measured
actually kind of helps conceptualize
that and so to measure it you take four
milliliters of water and eight
milliliters of water but I'm going to
put them in two petri dishes and then
add one hundred barley kernels to each
the number of kernels that germinate in
the formulator dish is taken to be the
germination percentage and then if you
take the number of kernels germinated in
the hundred mil in the formula g4
milliliter in dish
and subtract what germinates in the
eight milliliter dish you have the
Barley's water sensitivity so in this
little toy example if you have a hundred
kernels that germinate within the four
milliliter dish and then 60 they
germinate within the eight mil
milliliter dish you have a water
sensitivity of 40 for that bolting bar
the line or 40% it's reported both ways
so moving right along to what's known
about the trait so malting barley water
sensitivity is not something that has
been studied a lot it's kind of an open
field some of the most recent papers
upon it were actually published in the
60s and the most recent review on it is
from 1975 actually and in that review
brook said all states that had storage
conditions affect water sensitivity
along with the genotype the environment
during grain fill purportedly cool and
what weather increases water sensitivity
and then the time post physiological
maturity so on top of this there are
some seed physiologists that have looked
at this straight within barley in the
early 2000s and their eventual
hypothesis was that hypoxia causes
kernel causes the kernel embryo to
increase its ABA sensitivity which in
turn induces the secondary dormancy and
those studies were not done under the
name of water sensitivity at all they
are actually republished only in seed
physiology books and best of my
knowledge that hasn't crossed over into
breeding at all so moving right along we
set out to test three of these items and
those were the genotype the environment
during grain fill and the time post
physiological maturity to do that we
selected one of the populations that was
going to be grown already this was a
regional malting barley trial we
selected a subset of 20 lines there was
five checks and fifteen potential
varieties are on their least varieties
there was two locations in each location
had two replicates for each variety and
enough grain was sampled to
take about a time point one time point
per month after physiological maturity
for water sensitivity and then there's
some other questions that were asking
thank you there's some other questions
that we're asking with other populations
but these are not being discussed
currently because we don't really have
minute much with many results for them
at all yet so so a little bit of there's
a little bit of data analysis so we
analyzed the regional plots with
following model the phenotype being a
function of the entry the entry by
location and location and air with
location being the only fixed effect and
the entry being the genotype and then
haribol heritability was calculated in a
pretty standard manner for a balanced
for balanced data set so the first thing
that we were looking at is there is
there a genetic effect and heritability
is at least reasonably high for the
water sensitivity trait they get the
laser pointer up here you'll see so this
is I go back write heritability is
reasonably high for the water
sensitivity trait it all right things
are going wrong here so we have laser
pointers not on why is it not on so we
have reasonably high heritability
throughout the traits and G is actually
the germination percentage it's called
germination energy within the malting
barley field and that's high at all time
points water sensitivity increases
steadily in heritability and we think
that's actually because the actual
dormancy interferes with the measurement
of this induced secondary dormancy so if
we look at these first two time points
for the germination percentage we see
that there is a lot of residual dormancy
11 and 33 days past geologic maturity
and that corresponds well with the low
heritability water sensitivity but if we
drop those first two time points we can
still see that water since did that he
is changing over time
so we've got lines that are wrapped that
have a great increase in water
sensitivity in between 61 and and 89
days posting physiological maturity and
we have ones that are remaining
reasonably constant so with that we
conclude that water sensitivity does
change every time and lastly we can see
that water sensitivity is strongly
influenced by the environment and we
only have two time points as of now but
it does appear to be a consistent a
consistent effect so we have Snyder
always being having a smaller effect on
it than Caldwell interestingly enough
Snyder was actually the location of
Snyder was actually harvested about a
month before the location at Caldwell
meaning that Caldwell actually had
hotter and drier conditions during
Granville which goes against the trends
that was mentioned by Brooks at all and
as you said we thought that cool and wet
environments contribute more to water
since it have a greater water
sensitivity effect so with more data we
should be able to validate these trends
and that will be very interesting to see
so moving on to conclusions we can
conclude that time does change water
sensitivity in this population the
environment does play a substantial role
and it's actually the relationship is
contrary to what has previously been
stated in literature and then the
genotype does play a large role within
water sensitivity the effective storage
cannot be determined as of now and then
lastly the future plans to design some
experiments to test for water since a
sample and test for water sensitivity
within the barley populations next year
to test this effective storage as much
as we can to do a kernel number
optimization because as you can imagine
counting hundreds and thousands of
Barley's kernels takes a while so if we
can decrease the amount of kernels we
have to test at each time point so it
increased the amount of lines that we
can get through the system
the further assays for these coming time
points you notice I only had four or
five time points there we still have
five more to go
and then the testing of a large diverse
panel and the associated G wasps for the
genetic architecture of water
sensitivity and so that's that's what I
have for you I'd love to take questions
Thank You Travis yes we have plenty of
time for questions
[Music]
not not so the question was is there any
other influence on water sensitivity
apart from the environment there's the
storage conditions which we haven't
tested it could be that humidity the the
the the moisture percentage of the
colonel's influences the water
sensitivity at the time that the test is
being done there it's it's sort of up in
the air currently but I figured nobody's
done a review of it since 1975 that must
mean that monsters aren't terribly this
is true why so so the reason that is is
because molting has been for the past 50
years highly centralized with the advent
of small-scale malt houses this is a
trait that small still small scale
motels
I'm very difficult to deal with because
when if you've got a large scale you've
got a large batch process you can pretty
easily incorporate methods that will
deal with the water sensitivity as is
needed on a year on a yearly basis I
would assume and so it hasn't been a
trait that has been published upon but
small scale malls houses really have a
hard time dealing with it the idea for
this came from one of so Erin McLeod is
a high Brewing chemist at Hartwick
College and he said that his input has
been that water sensitivity is something
that's very difficult for small motors
to do
I understand so like image or Busch able
to do small-scale tests every barley
imagine comes in determining exactly yes
and then adjust adjust their schedule
accordingly yeah that would be so the
statement was that an either Bush or
other large multi sirs would sample each
batch that came in then adjust the
malting schedule accordingly and that
would be what I would assume would be
correct which also ultra also opens up
an interesting Avenue if they have all
that data and they're willing to share
it there would be molecular biology or
in genetic ways of testing the
hypothesis yes that's I haven't thought
too much about it that's so the the the
C physiologist that studied this back in
2006 or so they they did they studied
the effect of the of ABA on on it in
more of a physiology and file and
molecular biology standpoint and so that
would be something that that I can draw
on if I need to do that sort of test do
we have any questions on zoom all right
no questions on zoom let's thank Travis
one more time this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
Cornell edu